і Гончаренко - європейська Солідарність
шановні друзі Ви зараз хочете цією
постановою ще чергового опозижиста
ставити в чергову комісію скажіть ну як
Ну вам Ну от вас нічого нема з цим
ніяких проблем ви не відчуваєте якісь
проблеми з цим він відчуваєте проблеми
що кум медведчука продовжує тут нас бути
головою комітету ниністор ні літописец
можем Медведчук і нас залишається
народним депутатом України можете
Давайте його зараз оберемо головою
комітету наприклад з національної
безпеки нічого Ні ну як це можна знайти
ви пояснити що люди виключаючи тих яких
нема в країні з лютого місяця які
виїхали до 24 лютого напевно щось знали
і вони продовжують залишатися народними
депутатами України вам все гаразд все
нормально і інші написали власноруч
заяви про вихід
подивились спочатку чи не захопить Путін
Київ побачили що не захопив тоді
написали заяви власноруч Це пряма
конституційна підстава позбавити їх
вантажів чого ви це не робите А зараз ви
Навпаки ще ставите їм переводити з
комітету в комітет тримайте на посадах І
взагалі в комітетів Ви не хочете забрати
мандат зараз сумніватись з
конституційності чогось так заберіть
хоча посади які в них досить пір
залишаються ви нічого цього не робите Ну
як це можна пояснити Ну невже настільки
важливо що вони повністю здались вам і
зручно готові за все голосувати Ну як це
це що достатньо підстава для вас щоб
тримати цей русский мир в українському
парламенті після всього що було після
кожної хвилини мовчання яку ви
оголошуєте на початку І ми стоїмо і
згадуємо наших героїв друзі Схаменіться
вигнать русские мир з українського
парламента зараз